how many beers did you drink at the
Eagles game on Sunday oh it was a lot
probably how many give me 12 I'd say
that's 20. so that's 20. but you know I
was responsible I brought there's these
things called session ipas and they're
real low alcohol ipas like four percent
alcohol so I I brought those so I could
nurse them and I knew it was going to be
a marathon did you wear a diaper so you
didn't have to miss the game no there
was a bucket with kitty litter in it and
I just pissed in that what do you mean
you forgot the kitty litter bucket you
you you brought to the game a kitty
litter bucket one of our friends did and
they put a little tent around it and you
just go in this little tent and there's
a bucket with kitty litter and then you
just piss and it filled up somebody had
to go empty it and read kitty litter it
when you walk in with a big metal bucket
filled with kitty litter do they ever
say like hey you can't bring that in no
well we were tailgating so people bring
it
what do you do during the game when you
got a piss and you're drinking all that
beer oh well then I go to a bathroom and
yeah you do okay yeah no I act like a
civilized human then but in the parking
lot I'm in the Anderson you got to
devise ways to pee in the parking lot